they were exciting thing about the games
is it transforms itself almost a daily
basis the technology advances the
experience and opportunities and also
creates problems like no other
entertainment industry but the starting
point has to be a great game you haven't
got a great game
don't even bother the controllers of
consoles games are quite intimidating
got 15 button so it requires a certain
amount of knowledge so well as a large
nice audience playing console games it
was never really mass-market
entertainment I mean Apple really nailed
the user interface with swipe technology
suddenly enabling people who had never
thought about playing games to be able
to play games games like Angry Birds and
wares with friends and fruit ninja and
Temple Run and clash of clans these are
very engaging games and more recently
candy crush saga just millions upon
millions more people are playing games
and suddenly realising these aren't so
bad after all this is not such a dark
are after all it's actually quite good
fun and engaging and when the social
aspects of it whether it's online versus
with friends you know or people who
don't even know to have some chat and
community I think is a wonderful thing
and so the whole games world is being
demystified as more and more people are
playing on smartphones and tablets the
games industry has moved from a premium
pricing point to a freemium pricing
points he used to be physical goods
celled at retail for a fixed price 40 50
pounds or the dollar euro equivalent and
that was inflexible but today online and
more recently on tablet they've moved
from a subscription-based model to a
freemium model whereby it's free at the
point of delivery and during the game
you were given opportunities to be up
sold through microtransactions contents
a game has to be amazing if it's free
because no one's gonna spend any money
inside their game unless they're having
a great time if you give them a good
rubbish game and it's free they're not
gonna buy anything so if you're having a
good time you're more likely spend money
now of all the millions of people
playing only between 1 & 5 percent of
people actually spend money inside these
games
but the numbers so big that the revenues
from that small percentage of people
generates huge amounts of revenue for
the successful titles because let's not
forget for every angry bird there's
probably 20,000 dead birds out there on
the up still physical ballgames which
you see around you here
I still play but clearly a lot of those
games of being ported onto digital
devices Plus purely digital games are
being created by the hundreds of
thousands these days and just the way we
are in the world but there's ebooks
music physical components are
disappearing and that in a way is a
wonderful opportunity cuz content
creators no matter where in the world
can reach global audiences very
high-speed broadband the traditional
gatekeepers are no longer blocking the
way and you're not having to put loads
of money upfront to create products in
the old world you have to for games for
example you to spend an awful lot of
money on development and then you have
to make a physical media put them on
trucks put them in shops and get returns
build inventory this is quite a
laborious and very costly process and
some of the people have stood in their
way
have you reaching your audience often
didn't know what the hell they were
talking about but now you can reach
global audiences directly and with the
democratization of raising funding
through Kickstarter open other
crowdfunding ranges you can find out
whether or not your idea is viable
before you've had to start the project
and you can find it your own audience so
this is brilliant it's allowing new ways
of creativity to reach an audience new
ways of playing and and guess people who
are often not wanted out of the way it's
almost like the second golden age of
games is happening it's small teams
bootstrapping sometimes working at home
doing it for nothing with friends are
able to get content up there and they
learn through that it's getting what
they say getting water through the pipes
to learn the business
and when they've had a few apps out
there and it might not have monetize
much but they've learned a lot
especially about the backend and about
virality and and and discovery that's
the big challenge how am I gonna get my
game known about often comes back to
old-fashioned marketing buying installs
and leveraging the paid for in stores
with free installs once you get your
chart position but it's it's learning
that the whole thing and the whole PR
social media reviewers back the old
world of getting your product known it's
funny with games industry because like
in any industry you have to be know what
you good at and know what you're bad at
now a lot of creative people to start
off games companies yeah brilliant at
making games but they're not often
brilliant at making running companies so
to build real value in a company you
have to create your intellectual
property try and retain ownership of it
and scale your business now it reaches a
point when you realize that you can't do
everything so you need to partner with a
business person which often happens and
sometimes successfully sometimes not the
reason why it doesn't happen is that
suddenly the business people you employ
suddenly big think big they know a lot
about games and they start making
decisions and they tend to want to make
games from yes dear Ron tomorrow so the
crisis and the business should
absolutely work in tandem together both
know in their own areas neither of them
taking control because you know the
business people certainly have an
opinion about games as a creative people
they don't something have an opinion
about what's you know spreadsheets that
they're gonna use or what accounting
packages are going to use but everyone
seems have an opinion on products and
that's often where it goes wrong
it's not just the pricing points moving
from a premium to premium pricing points
games are moving from a box product to a
digital service and at that point now a
game is forever in beta and through
analytics a metrics you find out what
bits of a game consumers like and what
abyss the game they don't like so of
course because it is a service you're
gonna give more what they like unless of
what they don't like and during that
course buy forever improving your game
it gives you more opportunities of
course to monetize your consumers